JJ BEHRENS: Welcome
to Dartisans.
Today we're going to have
Web Components reloaded.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Oh, man.
This is good stuff.
JJ BEHRENS: We have
Dimitri Glazkov.
Is that the proper
pronunciation?
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: As
good as it gets.
JJ BEHRENS: Now, you're like
the grandfather of Web
Components.
Does that mean like the kind of
grandfather like when you
baptize someone, or the
kind of grandfather
who carries a gun?
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: I'm more
like an uncle, actually.
I take something--
JJ BEHRENS: An uncle?
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: --yeah, that
somebody was raised those
components a long time ago.
And I'm just trying to
take care of them
as best that I can.
You know that movie?
John Candy, you know.
JJ BEHRENS: You got to take
care of, cherish the Web
components.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Exactly.
JJ BEHRENS: You know, the future
is a delicate thing and
we have to make it
happen gently.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: I like it.
I like where this [INAUDIBLE]
is going.
JJ BEHRENS: So later in the show
we're going to have John
Messerly and Siggi Cherem and
they're going to talk about
Dart Web Components.
And so this is a twofer.
I'm super excited.
This is like--
a lot of effort went
into this show.
I'm super excited about this.
So why don't you get us started
and tell us what these
Web Components things are?
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: I'm also super
excited, by the way.
Just, you know, not
to be outdone.
So Web Components is really an
umbrella term for a bunch of
things that are happening in
the Web platform to kind of
makes things normal for
web developers.
This work is being done in the
World Wide Web Consortium web
apps working group.
And Chrome has bits that
have landed and are
running right now.
And Mozilla is landing
some bits.
Microsoft and Opera
are participating.
So this is kind of like
a broad effort.
And we're trying to go and take
our time and make sure we
get this right.
So this is where you guys are
going to be really important.
Please listen to this, identify
the points that seem
weird, and talk to us, because
this better be done right.
So why are we doing
this whole thing?
The interesting thing is that,
as you may have found out, the
web apps are for real.
So people write complex,
big web apps.
And when the web was first
developed, web software
engineering wasn't really a
thing, because when you just
want to write a few small
scripts, it's not
that big of a deal.
You really don't need software
engineering for it.
But the scripts have gotten
more complex.
There was more stuff written.
There was more and more code.
And suddenly, we've gotten to
the point where it's like, OK.
We have to figure out how
to do this rationally.
And the biggest problem that we
found is that the platform,
the web platform as we know it,
really backs all the way
up to the DOM.
The DOM, the document.body,
query element, querySelector,
getElementByTagName, and all
that stuff, all these things
are the lowest level that the
web developer can sense-- can
feel on this thing.
And the problem is that some
of the primitives that
developers--
an engineer would expect in any
normal software platform
are missing.
If you look at this
object-oriented programming,
the tenets are encapsulation,
inheritance, polymorphism.
You can get it if you have a
nice programming language.
But once you get down to the
platform level and start
dealing with the DOM objects,
those are just magic forests
with elves and fairies.
You can't figure out what
the hell's going on.
And you can't extend them, you
can't hide things, you can't
encapsulate things.
And so really, the choices at
that point we have are either
work around it or not
write complex apps.
So clearly, the choice of
workaround seems a little bit
more preferable than
not writing complex
apps or giving up.
And so the types of workarounds
you would see were
generally in two categories.
Either you fight the DOM or
you build an abstraction
around the DOM-- like
jQuery is a really
good example, right?
Every object you get out of
jQuery is actually a jQuery
object which wraps the DOM
to protect the poor user
from the evil DOM.
So you're basically actively
fighting this.
And then there's things like
SproutCore and Sencha, and now
Montage, that basically say,
hey dudes, we're going to
build our own thing.
And we're going to make
our own object tree.
And this object tree will
magically talk to the DOM tree
and make it somehow work.
And you just don't worry your
pretty head about this.
And the other one is, of course,
screw the DOM, right?
You basically say, oh,
Canvas, awesome.
OK, I'm just going to draw my
entire thing on Canvas and
everything's going
to just work.
The problem here is that you
still need an object tree.
You'll still need to handle
accessibility.
things like selection and
[INAUDIBLE]
support, right?
And at that point, once you've
handled all those things,
you've written a rendering
engine that is a lot of
JavaScript code that has to come
load and all this stuff.
So all these workarounds
are kind of sad.
And what I wanted to do--
when I came in, I was a web
developer for about 15 years
before I started working
on this.
As I said, I don't
want to be sad.
I want to be happy.
You know, Happy is like
my middle name.
It's Dimitri Happy Glazkov,
by the way.
And so what I said is, dudes,
let's fix this.
Let's figure out a way of how
we're going to make this work
in the platform, so that you
don't have to fight the DOM.
And you don't have to build your
own rendering engine to
get good results.
So that you would actually
enjoy the DOM.
And so what we kind of figured
out is that let's take those
tenets of object-oriented
programming and let's figure
out how we can naturally,
organically--
that's the key word, right--
green, organic, no pesticides.
We applied them inside of the
existing system, which means
that we use the DOM.
We just tweaked the DOM to
allow these wonderful
principles.
So, for example, for
encapsulation, we invented
shadow DOM.
We didn't really invent it.
It was invented a long time
ago by a lot of people.
There's people from Microsoft
who came up with a bunch of
crazy ideas that were
really good at some
point related to HTC.
And I don't know if
you're familiar
with the HTML behaviors.
There's Mozilla, that has XBL.
And all of those things--
SVG even has its own version
of shadow DOM.
And so the shadow DOM
basically says this.
Look dudes, we will make sure
that the developer of whatever
widget is being developed--
let's called this
developer Bob--
Bob the builder, right?--
does not have to worry about
what the consumer of this
widget-- let's call him, in best
traditions of Minecraft,
let's call him Steve, right?
Steve does not have to
worry what Bob built.
And Steve can't screw
things up.
Does that make sense?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: And so if
you kind of look in the
encapsulation, there's like
two things in there.
First, Bob wants to defend
against Steve.
Bob built the widget.
He doesn't want Steve to come
in and muck with it.
And then, at the same time,
Steve wants to say, oh, I have
this widget from Bob and now I
want to be using it reliably
without it breaking apart at
some point and stuff starting
to spill out from it.
And suddenly, all my things--
I changed the style
and suddenly
everything's green there.
I don't know why.
Something happened.
And so that's what encapsulation
is about.
And generally, if you kind of
think about it, is we give
Steve, the user of the widget,
their own documentry.
And we give Bob their
own widgetry.
And so they can work
inside of the tree
and not have to worry.
We will protect.
We will be the encapsulation
boundary inside of this thing.
And so that's what shadow
DOM really is about.
And the second one, we looked
and said, well, inheritance
seems nice.
Every programming language
in some shape or form has
inheritance.
But again, once you back up
into the DOM, there's no
inheritance.
There's just things.
And those things are there.
HTML development.
Der.
What if I want to build
my own thing?
What if I want to inherit
from that?
You can't, right?
So what we decided is we're
going to let you do that.
And that's what custom
DOM elements do.
They essentially allow you to
take any DOM object and say,
well, I want to build my own
type of thing that's just like
that and inherit from that.
And so it's just like--
if you kind of listen to this
and you've never build web
apps before, you keep going,
what the hell?
What are they talking about?
And the web developer's
going, yep.
That makes sense.
No, it doesn't make sense.
All of these things should
have been there in the
beginning and they weren't.
And so now we have to kind
of retrofit them
to make them work.
And finally, the last bit that's
really important is the
simple principle that you should
be able to take a chunk
of DOM and define it in some
declarative fashion and then
use it later.
Oh my god!
New concept, right?
No, not a new concept--
very simple thing.
Why can't you have that?
And so the basic idea is that
you should be able to use
what's called HTML templates.
And you can just specify
and say, this thing I'm
going to use later.
Don't render it.
Don't load images.
Don't fetch resources.
I'm going to use it later.
Just hang on.
And then the other thing is
it's obviously declarative
syntax, so you can just
write it as HTML.
And in addition to that, we're
adding this cool feature
called packaging, which means
that instead of just being
able to include just JavaScript
into your page, you
can include something that's
called a "package," or link
Rail components, and you
link to an HTML file.
And then the browser can then
suck in all the resources from
it, like CSS, JavaScript, and
markup and all those things
into one thing.
So this is amazing, right?
It seems like such an amazing
breakthrough--
to web developers, again.
To non-web developers it's
like, what the hell.
Why didn't you have
this before?
And so if you want to learn
more about it, just go to
Google+ and search for
Web Components.
There's a page that tracks all
the latest presentations.
There's a bunch of
them out there.
Some of them are really,
really awesome.
JJ BEHRENS: I liked
your Google I/O
presentation, by the way.
That was pretty good.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Right.
JJ BEHRENS: And then there's
also the Web Components
explainer--
when I search for that, it
always comes up with the
document, which is actually
really easy to read, unlike a
lot of specifications.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Yep.
And so try not to get drowned
in the specs, because those
are really technical language
things that were primarily
written not for you.
They were primarily written for
the engineers who build
browsers, so that we can assure
that whoever builds
this thing into the browser does
it the same way that the
other guy did.
And so we just have to make sure
this is specified right.
So please dig in and look
at those things.
And now I'm going to hand it off
to these wonderful folks
that are around here.
JJ BEHRENS: So I'm just curious,
now that we're going
to implement all the interesting
normal things that
we have in programming
languages-- we're going to
have encapsulation.
We're going to have
inheritance.
What other cool things
can we steal
from programming languages?
It's like--
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Yeah,
we just need to keep
stealing stuff, right?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
Well, I think that we just need
to read some papers back
from MIT A.I. Lab in the '70s.
And every time we see something
interesting, we'll
just steal it, shove
it in the browser.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: It's really
surprising, because in a lot
of sense, the libraries that I
was just disparaging for how
they're working around things
are a huge informer in this
whole process.
Because by reading those
libraries and understanding
what trouble they're
encountering and the length
they have to go into to
make things work is
what informs the spec.
And what says, oh,
we can fix this.
JJ BEHRENS: So, to what degree
would you say Angular JS fed
into Web Components?
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: We
actually talked to
Angular JS folks a lot.
They have influenced a lot of
the early decisions and a lot
of general thinking.
It was really cool.
And they have to, again,
fight those battles.
And the design decisions they
make are heavily influenced by
what's really possible.
Whereas we kind of have
this cool ability.
We can say, hey, we're
the browser people.
We can make it work.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, if only
we knew someone
who worked at a browser.
Oh wait, we do.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Exactly.
Exactly.
JJ BEHRENS: So I know
that model-driven
views are not really--
I don't remember reading any
about them in the Web
Components spec.
But it seems like Web Components
is this umbrella
term that has come to encompass
Model-driven Views
in the same way that we
use HTML5 for a bunch
of different APIs.
What do you have to
say about that?
It seems like MDV is important
these days.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Model-driven
Views is simply, again,
rationalizing the patterns that
we've seen so many times.
So many libraries out there are
embracing templating patterns--
the Mustache, the Ember.gs--
all these guys are looking at
this idea that you should be
able to declare stuff and
then put in the holes.
And then run it against some
sort of a data set.
And suddenly, boom,
things go alive.
It seems like, again, like
this is Mr. Obvious.
This is very simple.
But what we're trying with MDV
to do is we're trying to first
concentrate on what are the
things that are truly missing
from the platform that don't let
you this nice ability to
do this type of data binding.
And there's two things that
are really exciting, the
observation-related things.
If you want to be able to bind
to data, you have to be able
to first observe what DOM
objects are doing.
You have to say hey,
this thing changed.
I better react to it somehow.
And this is where-- we used
to have thing called
the mutation events.
Nasty, nasty, nasty thing,
because first of all, mutation
events are really slow.
They're synchronous.
And they are like the wrong
thing, because in a typical
web application, the DOM
tree changes a lot.
And that results in a lot
of mutation events.
And instead, we came up with
this whole new abstraction
called mutation observers.
And those are a much more
elegant designed thing that's
specifically aimed at
solving the problem,
observing DOM changes.
And then you look at the
opposite and say, hey, now I
want to be able to look
at the data objects.
And when they change, I want to
be able to know about it.
JJ BEHRENS: So this is a big
deal in terms of performance,
because I've seen some graphs
where if you have to do dirty
checking, which is what you
have to do today, versus
having it built into the
platform, the performance
differences are amazing.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Absolutely,
yes.
It's crazy, like
20 to 40 times.
JJ BEHRENS: Not 20% to 40%,
but 20 to 40 times faster.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: I almost said
percent, because it doesn't
even come out right.
Times!
JJ BEHRENS: Times faster.
That's just--
that enables a new type
of application
when you can do that.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: That's right.
JJ BEHRENS: So I know that
one of our questions--
I skimmed through them really
quickly, but I think one of
them would be good for you.
And he was asking, what is the
benefit of including this in
the browser instead of just
relying on more libraries to
provide this for us?
And we just talked about the
performance benefits, but can
you think of other benefits?
Why do we want this
in the browser?
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Well,
performance, leaky
abstractions, and just
generally painless
development.
I don't need to include
something in order to start.
This is my platform.
This is where I live.
This is where I want
to work in.
And so if you say, well,
my platform is not
actually web platform.
It's actually SproutCore.
Well, that means you're working
on a different platform.
So what we want to do is we
want to come down to the
platform level and enable as
many of those features--
but the most important thing
is that by enabling those
features in the browser,
if we're doing
it in a smart way--
smartly, I guess that's
the word--
what we do is we also inform the
browser a lot better about
what's happening.
And when we do that, we have a
lot of opportunities that are
still not even discovered fully
of where the browser can
go faster, can use less memory,
and can essentially do
the job better.
And we can really accelerate
the pace and the speed of
loading, the way applications
operate, and the way they
[? feel. ?]
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I also think
that with a lot of these
widget libraries, they're trying
really hard, but it
definitely seems like it's hard
to get interoperability
between these frameworks.
And I definitely would love to
see a point where we have all
of these rich Web Components
and then we can share them
between libraries, so we don't
get into situations where I
see this beautiful widget but
I can't use it because it's
not using the same
framework I am.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: And there's
actually a really interesting
effort that's coming
out of the Mozilla.
And they're called x-tags.
They're really interested in
this problem of what if we
could define some way to say
this is the best practices of
how to build these
web components.
They're not necessarily all
difficult, hard rules, but
just a general set of things.
And if you follow these
practices, all the components
are interoperable.
So that's kind of a cool
thing that's happening.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So I'm going to start segueing,
but I got one last
question for you.
Having watched the Google I/O
talk, your Google I/O talk,
I've seen the future.
How do I get there?
If I want Web Components today
and I don't want to wait
because I'm impatient,
what do I do?
What do we do?
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: There's some
bits of it that are in Chrome.
Some bits of it--
actually, Mozilla is going to
land some of these really
interesting things related to
custom DOM elements very soon.
But there's also polyfills,
or shams, for things
that you can use.
And generally, it's not
100% fidelity, but
it's pretty darn good.
So you can start experimenting
with this stuff.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for coming and giving
us a great explanation.
And now we're going
to talk to John
Messerly and Siggi Cherem.
And of course, I got to ask
again, did I pronounce it
correctly or not?
SIGGI CHEREM: That
sounds wonderful.
JOHN MESSERLY: You got it.
SIGGI CHEREM: You got it.
JJ BEHRENS: So you guys are--
where are you guys again?
SIGGI CHEREM: We're up
here in Seattle.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
And I've heard rumors that in
Seattle the sun is always
shining, because it's raining
out here in Mountain View.
Is this true?
JOHN MESSERLY: It's true today,
for what that's worth.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: We've
proved it.
The sun always shines
in Seattle.
JOHN MESSERLY: Well, maybe
it's not true anymore.
JJ BEHRENS: Always, by
a sample size of one.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Good
enough for me.
JJ BEHRENS: I have no--
I cannot hear them.
So you guys have a nice
presentation.
You guys are going to talk
about how to do Web
Components in Dart.
Why don't you take it away?
SIGGI CHEREM: Cool.
So basically, we're very glad
that Dimitri is here and
presented right before us,
because we basically are
working on top of a lot of the
ideas that had been developed
in the [? standards and ?] web
community and a lot of the
work that Dimitri has been doing
and essentially adapting
it to work also in Dart.
Now, basically, the goal here
is very similar to a lot of
the motivation that
we heard earlier.
We want to have happy users,
people that can actually get
an application that runs
fast, that is secure by
construction, and essentially,
they can use great web
applications.
And we want developers in the
process to actually be happy
creating these web
applications.
That means writing less code
than what we used to, having a
way of iterating quickly and
somehow be able to change your
code and not have to be stalled
or slowed down by a
huge infrastructure that
essentially you have to wait
on before you can actually
do a change and see it
immediately in the browser to
see whether or not it worked.
And something stable enough that
you can then split the
work with a lot of people, be
able to have a team of 5,10,
50 developers working together
and be able to collaborate
without having to do so much
coordination as we have today.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
Gets back to the good software
engineering stuff that Dimitri
was alluding to earlier.
SIGGI CHEREM: So we know
there've been many frameworks
out there to compensate or sort
of work around issues
that we have in browsers
today.
And examples of that
are Angular JS,
Ember, and many more.
And that motivated a lot of the
work that Image is doing
of creating new web standards
that incorporate a lot of
these principles into
the platform.
So we have the standards for Web
Components and there's now
this new more experimental
proposals for MDV
templates as well.
So what we decided to do for
Dart is say, we're going to
embrace these proposals.
We're going to take them
as if they exist today.
In the meantime, we're going to
sort of polyfill and make
sure we can actually use them,
but by embracing them, we're
actually going to be with
some beneficial
factors in the long run.
JJ BEHRENS: I love this part of
it, because we don't have
to wait for the future for Web
Components in the Dart world.
We can start using them today.
That's just awesome.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, that's
exactly right.
So there's this term that
you may have heard.
I think Dimitri mentioned it.
But if you haven't heard
it, it's polyfill.
And it's kind of this notion
that the web is a bit rough
around the edges.
You're really programming for
four to five major browsers,
or just on the desktop, you've
got your mobile ones.
And they're all a little
bit different.
So you're not just programming
against a system.
You're programming against
many systems, and there's
rough edges between them.
And so polyfill is this kind of
spackle that you've put in.
You fill in the holes
between browsers.
And the good news
now is that--
we use this term a lot, you
may have heard, "modern
browsers." But it's basically
kind of an allusion to the
fact that like JavaScript is
fast in all the browsers now,
which is important for Dart
because we compile the
JavaScript.
And in particular, IE9
is really good.
So we can actually bring some of
these new features and have
it work everywhere your
users will want
to run their programs.
SIGGI CHEREM: So now, by
embracing these web standards,
we get benefit that people like
Dimitri have been working
really hard in designing the
system so that they take a lot
into consideration all the
designs of older systems like
Angular and so on.
So we benefit a lot from that
hard work and all the history
that's behind us.
At the same time, we have to
adapt it to make it work in
Dart, so we have opportunities
to provide feedback and to
make sure that is something that
is not just meant to work
only in JavaScript, but also in
a context that is a little
bit more generic and agnostic
of what language
it's running in.
And once this actually makes it
into the platform and the
old browser's implemented, that
means that our library
will basically keep
producing inside.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, if you
haven't seen this Vapor.js,
you should check it out.
It's pretty funny.
It's basically a JavaScript--
it's the world's
smallest ever--
smallest possible JavaScript
library.
[INAUDIBLE] good.
JJ BEHRENS: You know,
that's funny.
I was code reviewing it before
we did this Hangout.
It didn't take me long.
Although, I was still
complaining about--
I wanted to complain about
the indentation settings.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
And the important point there is
just that a lot of people,
when they choose frameworks,
they look for really small
JavaScript libraries.
They will frequently advertise
that this library gives you
all this power and only 3K.
And I think that by building
stuff into the browser, we can
both give you tons of
capabilities and, eventually
over time, reduce the size of
code you have to import.
JJ BEHRENS: And in general, this
isn't really so much a
problem in Dart anyway, because
we have a tree shaking
and dead code elimination.
So you can use whatever
libraries you want to use and
not worry so much about 2K of
code that you're not actually
using, because it'll get
stripped out immediately.
JOHN MESSERLY: Mm-hm.
JJ BEHRENS: So what's
available in Web
Components for Dart?
SIGGI CHEREM: So there's
basically a blend of Web
Components features and
templating features.
And on the Web Components
side, basically we have
polyfills for a lot
of the things that
Dimitri talked about.
So there's a notion of custom
elements, being able to define
your own tags, and the notion
of the shadow DOM.
When it's actually available
in a browser,
we'll try to use it.
But we can also polyfill and
single add those features.
And things like extension and
composition, so you can then
inherit from other components
and be able to have components
that inject data that
you can [INAUDIBLE]
elements where you use them.
And on the templating side,
there is the notion of data
binding, conditional,
iterations, inlining event
listeners-- things that are
common to templating system,
then, are also some of this
part of what MDV is
specifying.
But essentially, we have adapted
them to work more
closely to have Dart breaks.
And a lot of these bindings
and things are expressing
things in syntax that is very
linked to that language.
So when you put all these things
together, basically, we
have all the tools we need to
build large web applications
following very nice patterns.
And if you're familiar with
web development, or, in
general, application
development, it's very common
that you want to create some
division of your application
in models, views and
something else.
It could be a controller or a
percenter or something that
would plow data through
the UI.
And the UI changes back
to your system.
JJ BEHRENS: That's funny.
I've never heard of MV
asterisk pattern.
SIGGI CHEREM: Well, I mean--
JOHN MESSERLY: It's whatever
you want to put there.
Yeah, I think we're pretty
sympathetic to the model view,
view model if we had to pick
one, I think But they're all
different words to kind of
describe the extra glue.
SIGGI CHEREM: Exactly.
So in essence, when you think
about it, you have essentially
one part of your code is
dedicated to just the
percentage.
So that's why in this diagram
that we have here on this
slide is just saying
this is the UI.
Now, whenever a user interacts
with it, it starts running
some code that's essentially
a bunch of operations that
semantically represent what you
want your [INAUDIBLE] once
the user takes an action.
And those operations are
eventually going to change
your data model.
And then to close the cycle,
essentially as soon as the
change happens in your model, we
want to reflect that in the
UI and end up with a consistent
state in your screen.
So this cycle here is something
that every model
view star pattern essentially
tries to follow.
And the difference can come
in essentially how do you
actually make this update from
the DL layer to the UI.
Some people say, oh, let's
do those updates using a
controller.
Some people would actually do
basically just proactively
change the things from the
operations all the way
directly to the UI, kind
of shortcutting things.
And those kind of things
sometimes end up getting a
little bit of spaghetti
code and
making it hard to maintain.
So one thing that we really like
about having templating
features like data binding and
all the things is that you can
make the data and UI respondents
more reactive.
You just have some features that
are allotted to say this
portion of the UI is going to
just simply reflect whatever
the latest state
of the data is.
Whenever that changes, this will
be automatically changed.
And this automatic is
essentially the notion of
there will be an event and then
essentially a subsequent
change in the UI.
Just have to make sure
that those events
are triggered somehow.
JJ BEHRENS: You know, I really
like the way that MDV fits
into all of this, because I
remember working my way
through the "Agile Web
Development with Rails" book.
And there was this kind of thing
that has been the ugly
stepchild that no one
wants anymore, and
that's the RJS templates.
And do you guys remember this,
where you would write Ruby
code and it would generate
JavaScript on the fly to
update the UI?
And I just remember going
through all the exercises.
And it's like if I forgot to
write the right line, then I
would update one part of
the UI but not update
another part of the UI.
And the whole thing was kind
of a little bit strange to
begin with, because I have the
server trying to write
JavaScript to update the UI.
But with MDV, it's
really nice.
I change the data and the UI
automatically updates.
I mean, this is a big win.
SIGGI CHEREM: Yeah, exactly.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, another interesting part
about this, and this comes in
when you have components.
So you've got this kind of
fractal picture here, which
just shows that once you have
components, you can kind of
have something that completely
encapsulates its model and its
view and its events.
And that's really nice, because
now you've raise the
level of abstraction.
You can program against a very
rich, beautiful widget, not
worry about--
it may have tons of internal
state, and that's fine.
You never have to think
about that.
As long as the original
developer got it right, you
just use it.
And that's kind of an added
simplicity, I think, on top of
the-- you still want your
top-level app to have this
nice structure of separating the
different parts, but it's
very nice to have it be fully
recursive like this.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
I think the recursion is
a really good feature.
Again, coming from the Rails
world where we had model view
controller, but you
have one model.
And you're going to generate the
page using one model, one
view, and one template, and
then a bunch of helpers.
Whereas, sometimes I would get
into these widgets where I
wished the widget had
its own model.
And it was never really kind
of a first class citizen.
But with Web Components, each
web component is a full
citizen, can have
its own model.
And then you can have separate
models that are the
aggregation of a bunch of
other web components.
And I just love being able
to structure my app in a
fractal-like way, as you say.
SIGGI CHEREM: You know, I think
that's why we sometimes
prefer these MVVM, the Model
View ViewModel architecture,
where view model actually
represents the model that is
mainly associated with
view pieces.
And it's not so much about all
the background tasks or
synchronization data, the stuff
that you normally would
push all the way
to the server.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
SIGGI CHEREM: So we have
a bunch of examples in,
essentially, the articles
we publish in
the dublin.org website.
And we extracted a couple
examples here, just to
highlight some of the features
that we have on the templating
side of things.
And this first example
is actually
also from our website.
And one of the first things
that you can see is--
let me highlight that--
is what's the
notion of a data binding.
And in this example, you see
essentially is the notion of a
little piece of the UI that
shows a counter and the button
that increments the counter.
And what you see this double
braces with account inside,
it's saying, well, this is
actually the value of the
variable count.
Whenever that changes, I want to
reflect it here in the UI.
Similarly, this is sort of a way
of doing one of the edges
on the triangle we
saw earlier.
Another edge is saying, well,
how do I do UI events and
listen on UI events.
And you can do that declarative
as well.
The syntax here is very similar
to how back in the day
you used to have on the DOM the
notion of on events in the
DOM, which are typically very
discouraged because you don't
want to do that right upfront.
But this is more
a declaration.
This does not necessarily mean
one is going to run--
he hits a lot of [? pledges ?]
implicit in this that--
Dimitri was talking
about templates.
This is just I'm declaring
what the behavior is.
Later, we'll figure out
how to run this code.
And what means we're going to
run it, it just means when you
click on this thing, we're going
to cull the method that
is actually represented inside
of that event handlers.
In this particular example,
we'll increment the count.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I love the
fact that you update count and
automatically the UI updates.
But I'm going to have to say
that I really don't like the
syntax of the way you have
the double curly braces.
And I'll tell you why.
I'm a Python programmer
and I just think
that braces are ugly.
JOHN MESSERLY: No, you can
import them in Python, from
future import braces.
JJ BEHRENS: OK, so tell
me about iteration.
SIGGI CHEREM: Most decent
templating systems had a way
of going through the data and
iterating over it or having
conditional--
some notion of control flow.
But it's basically just saying,
I want to essentially
expand a section of my
[INAUDIBLE] in multiple times
for each one of the variables
in the collection.
So that's an example that
you can see now.
And this is from our TodoMVC
example that you can also find
in our product page.
So basically, iteration--
here's where we start doing some
of the changes to make it
a little bit more closer to how
you write things in Dart,
saying, well, we're going to
introduce here a syntax
similar to how [INAUDIBLE]
in Dart, even though it's
the same that MDV
uses for their templates.
[INAUDIBLE]
match.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
And we let you use
Dart Expressions.
So you'll note view model
dot is visible.
That's just Dart code
for the binding.
SIGGI CHEREM: So the next
[? binder ?] that you have
under it is a conditional
saying,
OK, this is a template.
And we're only going
to display if this
condition is true.
If it's not true, then
we're not going to
actually touch it.
So you could in fact have
expressions and bindings
inside of that conditional that
depend on the condition
that is above it.
So it's not that you have to be
[? preventive ?] about and
not [INAUDIBLE] your reception
or something of that sort.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
And the template actually--
that template node, that's the
thing Dimitri was alluding to
earlier, where it's saying
everything under this node is
inert until we do something--
until there's some condition
like iterate or f that causes
us to care about it.
And so I'll also talk about--
so now we'll highlight this
xTodo rail.
And that's basically--
that is a instantiation
of a web component.
So xTodo row, of course, if you
know HTML, you're like,
there's no tag like that.
And so that's a tag we made up
just for this application.
And we can just use
it in HTML.
And this is the thing, this
will work in browsers.
So that is just--
I want to make that point again
because I think that's
really exciting.
And then we can do data
binding with it too.
So just like we can do data
binding for a normal
attribute, we can do
data binding of a
field of our component.
And we can say, hey, when you
create this xTodo row, make
sure that you assign--
you fill in its Todo attribute,
its Todo field, in
Dart with the value of x.
SIGGI CHEREM: So basically,
let's show you what this Todo
row-- how it was written
initially.
Basically, when you write a
component, its similar to
declaring, essentially, a new
component in the DOM.
And when you think of DOM
elements, essentially they
have attributes that they
commonly have a corresponding
property, sort of that
matches the name of
that particular attribute.
And that's sort of
what we did here.
So when we're defining a
component, we're saying, well,
there's some fields in this
component class and one of
them is the actual Todo item.
That sort of linked
back to our model.
When we displayed the
view, we say, well,
it's like an LI element.
And it has a label that says
this the task that we have to
do and so on.
But what's interesting is that
then the binding that we did
on the previous slide was
basically just saying, well,
these attributes corresponds to
this particular property or
field in this particular
component.
JJ BEHRENS: I love the fact that
you could combine both
some markup as well as custom
code, so that the tag actually
has real meaning and those
two things are together.
But some people coming from--
I think it's a [INAUDIBLE]
background, they might not like
having the Dart code in
the same file as the
template code.
And what would you
suggest they do?
SIGGI CHEREM: You can simply
move the code to a
separate Dart file.
So what you see there is
there's a script that
essentially currently has an
inline Dart code in it.
You can switch that to put a
source tag that points to a
particular Dart file and move
the code into your Dart.
So that will give you the
benefit that if you're using
it from the Dart editor or
things like that, you at least
get proper syntax highlighting
and code
completion, it seems like.
JJ BEHRENS: So is the Dart
Editor going to get better
support for Web Components?
JOHN MESSERLY: Oh, yes.
For sure.
We'll talk more about that.
But yeah, the support for right
now is very basic, but
it's something we're looking
at making better.
JJ BEHRENS: OK, great.
So tell me how to run this
on modern browsers.
JOHN MESSERLY: So it's
really easy.
Well actually, yeah, since
we're talking about the
Editor-- so the easiest way to
do this is you can go to the
Editor welcome page of
the Dart Editor.
So you just download it.
You're on the welcome page and
you click the TodoMVC example.
And that's just a
starting point.
You can edit that, you
can delete stuff if
you don't like it.
But the basic idea is there's
this little file in there
called build.dart.
And it's really small.
And if you have one of those
in your project, the editor
knows every time you save an
HTML file, for example, they
know to run that code.
And so they'll call build.dart
and it will very quickly,
order of less than half a
second, update all the things
that it needs.
It will run our tool that
implements all these features.
And then you just go into
your output folder and
run your HTML page.
And so what we're also showing
on the slide is that same
exact flow works from
the command line.
So you run our tool, you run
Dart to JS exactly like you
normally would if you want to
run it in a browser other than
Chrome with Dart, Dartium.
And yeah, that's
pretty much it.
SIGGI CHEREM: So additionally
there's also--
you can follow that link that we
have there on the bottom on
Tools, how to set things up.
And one of the things we have
is we also have the Dartium
extension that basically,
once the compiler--
in an extension, it [? sniff ?]
that you have a
page that actually has
components, and then it would
actually compile it
automatically.
So you just save the file on
your file system, refresh, and
it would just work.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow, cool.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, we
really hate waiting.
If you've ever seen that--
there's an XKCD comic about
someone that--
people are dispensing because
they're waiting for their code
to compile.
We really hate waiting for
things to compile.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
The C++ programmers have to
wait minutes and we're
complaining over waiting
half of a second.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, exactly.
So we just want to make that--
you save your code, refresh it
in your browser, bam, you
see your changes.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty awesome.
JOHN MESSERLY: And so what I'm
sharing on this slide, you can
start using this now.
It's a very early stage.
Of course, Dart is
not 1.0 yet.
And if you follow the Dart
project, you've probably seen
on the mailing list there's
changes still happening to
some of the core libraries to
try to improve APIs and stuff.
But you can start
using this now.
This just summarizes all
the features we have.
And then, so where
are we going?
This is something I think a lot
of people want to know.
And we really want a
complete tool kit.
We don't want to stop--
we could give you
some features.
And I think it's already
incredibly useful, this basic
layer of templating
and components.
But as soon as you buy into
that, you're like, oh, well, I
like this, but I want
more stuff.
I want routing.
Help me automatically serialize
my objects.
Help me with local storage.
And so we basically want to
keep trying to fill in all
these pieces.
And we would love help, but one
important part of this is
as soon as you hear complete
stack, you might think, oh no,
this is going to be another
giant framework
I have to buy into.
And the answer to that is no,
you can pick and choose
whichever parts you want.
And that's very important to us,
because you may have your
own way of doing serialization
that's different from what we
think is the right thing.
And so another thing I just want
to throw out there, we
got asked this--
I think this alludes to one of
the questions, too, that I saw
on the list.
But how does this compare to
other JavaScript frameworks,
because there are a lot
of them out there.
And there was this
great article.
Throne of JS kind of picked
seven of the popular ones and
went through and found--
where do they agree and where
do they disagree?
And the agreement is good,
because that means there's now
this set of features where, as
a web developer, you can just
expect them.
Any good framework is
going to have them.
And then the points of
disagreement are interesting
too, because these are the
things that we're still all
trying to figure out
collectively.
And reasonable smart people
have different opinions.
JJ BEHRENS: I disagree.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, exactly.
So where do we stack
up on these?
So we've got one of the big
things is how you do
templating, DOM versus
String-based--
and basically, the String-based
people can say,
well, we've got these
extra features
like server-side rendering.
And the DOM-based people say,
well, we've got a better
programming model.
You just use HTML and you have
some magic attributes.
And you already saw that.
We already showed you.
So our templating is very
similar to the DOM approach.
But because we have a complete
HTML5 part [? server, ?] we
actually can implement some of
these neat features like
server-side rendering.
We don't have that yet, but it's
something that we've been
looking at.
So I think on this one we might
be able to get the best
of both worlds.
You want to talk about
the flexibility?
SIGGI CHEREM: Yeah.
So I think John was mentioning
earlier a little bit of this--
is this going to be a framework
impacted by
[INAUDIBLE] or not.
And this is one of the issues
that comes up a lot in this
comparison.
And in particular, I think we're
somewhere in the middle,
but we're flexible enough that
we're providing a library with
a lot of small pieces
that you can use.
So you can use the portion to
use watchers to watch for
changes in models,
for example.
But there's still some buy in in
just having to be using our
compiler in order to
use things today.
Eventually, what's happening
is that a lot of these web
components, in the end,
are web components.
So that means they're going to
become, essentially, a tag in
your system.
So you can then use this
tag somewhere else.
And you don't have to, in that
older part of the [? AR ?]
code, be using this sort
of technology of
Web Components itself.
So this sounds like
a neat tradeoff.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah, that's a
really good point, actually.
All of this is about
facilitating--
and then this is another
point of why you put
stuff in the browser.
We want to make it
so that this base
functionality is there.
And people who are developing
different
components can share them.
What a concept, developers
sharing libraries.
So I think that will be good.
And then we're totally--
right now, we're completely
server agnostic.
Use this with your Rail server,
use this with your
Jenga server if you're Python.
Use it with anything
you want, really.
We may eventually think about--
people have asked us,
well, what if I [? wrap my ?]
server Dart?
And we may do something there,
but it's just very early.
We haven't really thought much
about that yet, other than
kind of vague ideas.
But whatever we do there, we're
going to keep it working
with every server.
And then another difference that
I'll go into a little bit
more on the next few slides
is that we have very
little magic in models.
Almost all of these ones, if you
look at them, you have to
do something a little bit
special, some special
controller type that
you have to extend.
And we're trying to keep the
magic there to a minimum so
you're just using
Dart classes.
So I don't know if you want to
talk about the data binding
performance.
SIGGI CHEREM: Sure.
Part of the reason that we
really wanted to keep things
simple is that in the end, we
just want to be able to use
plain Dart objects in order to
write your models so that
everything plays nicely with
the rest of your system.
And that's something that we'd
really like to preserve.
Right now, we're doing things in
a way that, actually, there
is some cost associated with
that, in that we have to do
essentially some form of dirty
checking whenever you change
your model to make sure that
we have to update the UI or
not later on.
And the cost is sort of
proportional to the number of
data bindings you have
on the screen.
So some people worry that, well,
what if I have lots of
things on my screen?
That will be too expensive.
JOHN MESSERLY: Thousands.
SIGGI CHEREM: Thousand
of elements.
So then, if you do that, there
are still actually
opportunities to make
things faster.
And there are many actual
directions that we're
considering.
And we might explore
many of them.
So one of them is what really
needs to be on screen versus
what needs to be bound.
There's a little bit of tension
there, is that if you
have a table of 1,000 elements,
most likely the
thousand elements are
not visible at once.
It's more like you have a window
of them visible, and
then you want to render a
bigger table underneath.
So you can actually
create smart
components that know that.
And typical things that are
components that we've seen
them done in the past have
been like an infinite
scrolling list where you don't
know how much data is coming
and you keep scrolling
and scrolling.
And then you just are watching
for changes on the things that
are visible at a given moment.
And then there are things that
we can also consider.
Object [? upstart, ?] for
example, is something that's
been proposed in EcmaScript 6
so that there will be more
needed support to
observe objects.
And then we can actually take
advantage of that when we're
compiling to JavaScript.
JOHN MESSERLY: Exactly.
SIGGI CHEREM: But a third is,
since we have a compiler in
the picture, so far we've been
mostly processing the HTML
side of things.
But we can also process the Dart
side of things and make
classes with a special
annotation or have some
special types that allows to
then make them observable and
be more proactive.
Instead of doing dirty checking,
we just know
whenever something is mutated.
JOHN MESSERLY: And the next
couple slides basically show--
here's your model right
now, plain Dart class.
Very simple, right?
If you've programmed any Dart,
nothing surprising here.
And then, what does it look
like with these observable
annotations?
And I really hope that it ends
up exactly as lightweight as
this, because I think this is
a good programming model.
But we don't have that now.
So it's a good point to make,
that that's a future thing.
DIMITRI GLAZKOV: Oh, yeah.
That doesn't exist yet.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
That's something we're
going to look at.
SIGGI CHEREM: So basically,
that's what we had in the
presentation.
We put up here some
links at the end.
And they're very discoverable.
But we have article an
explaining article with lots
of examples.
And if you land in that page,
there are links to a more
formal specification of what are
the features available in
our web components, a table
summary of all those features
so you can have a quick
reference, and the links that
were project based and a
[INAUDIBLE] tracker.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
And I know Seth Ladd has been
blogging some really nice blog
posts about Web Components
on his blog.
And those really helped
me as well.
And I'm going to be coming out
with a code lab, so you could
learn how to build
your first app.
So that'll be pretty exciting.
So we have a few questions.
Let's go over these
real quick.
We have a few minutes left.
So is it possible to use
Google Closure Advanced
Compilation on the compiled
results of a Dart project with
Web Components, or can
the renaming of
properties cause problems?
JJ BEHRENS: So I would say
it's not necessary.
Dart is its own Closure
Compiler.
It does tree shaking and dead
code removal automatically.
What do you think?
SIGGI CHEREM: Yeah.
And I think this might be a
more general question of
generally in Dart code.
The JavaScript code that is
generated by Dart to JS is a
minimal [? minification. ?]
Now, one of the things that we
notice is that we have a lot
of type information that is very
rich at the Dart level
that can be used to minify
things a bit more aggressively
than what you can do, for
example, with a composure
compiler, where it has a
little bit more of a--
I guess if there's a lot of
similarities in the type
system of both, because they
give you still similar
opportunities, but--
JOHN MESSERLY: So actually,
they've recently added the
minify option to Dart JS.
And yeah, we looked
at this before.
Actually, I think maybe when we
came out about a year ago
with Dart publicly that there
was some problems with trying
to use Closure Compiler as the
optimization strategy, because
you're just throwing away
too much information.
And you have to figure
it all out again.
And we'll do something
good in Dart to JS.
I think that's a much
better way.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
So let's say I have a bunch of
content that I want indexed by
a search engine.
How could I use Web Components
to present the content while
still being search
engine friendly?
SIGGI CHEREM: Well, so that's
definitely something that we
have on the roadmap.
So all the code that we're
generating is--
right now, actually,
essentially, we should be able
to run some of this code on
the server side as well.
So basically, we have
a full [INAUDIBLE]
five part [? server ?]
that allows to then be able to
process all this and then be
able to generate the actual code
that you want the servers
to then say, this is what
you should index.
Now, we're not trying to go to
the full length of saying
we're going to render in the
server so that you bind the
rendering in your client.
This is a separate
feature just for
that particular purpose.
Yeah, so you can basically just
generate a static HTML
page against some--
you have to make the mock model,
of course, like what's
your data look like, that you
want a search engine to see.
But you'll just be able
to run it against--
JJ BEHRENS: And I
would say that--
I can neither confirm nor deny
anything, but I have seen
reports on the web that say it
is not safe to assume that
your search engine does not
understand JavaScript at all.
JOHN MESSERLY: True, true.
JJ BEHRENS: So will it be
possible to organize HTML and
Dart parts of Web Component
into separate files?
I think we answered that.
Is there are already a place
where people share their Web
Components, or are their plans
to have a public library of
common Web Components?
JOHN MESSERLY: Put
them on Pub.
JJ BEHRENS: Put them on Pub.
That's a good idea.
SIGGI CHEREM: That's something
that, just as a warning, it
doesn't work today.
But it will.
It's part of our goals.
We want to make it--
JOHN MESSERLY: It's
an M2 bug, right?
SIGGI CHEREM: We have
plans to fix that.
JJ BEHRENS: It's going
to happen.
And then, how do Web Components
compare to popular
Angular JS frameworks?
So I know that Dimitri
personally solved this earlier.
Do you guys have any things to
add to that from kind of a
Dart perspective?
How much are we inspired
by the Angular JS guys?
JOHN MESSERLY: A lot.
We've already been talking to
them for quite a while, and I
think we're going to basically
continue that, because they
just have so much experience
in real world applications
that are using Angular JS,
and even at scale.
So I think that there's just a
lot we can learn from them.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
So what's the lifetime
of a Web Component?
Is it entirely unloaded,
just removing the
node from the DOM?
If not, what is the
best practice to
manage memory with them?
JOHN MESSERLY: That's
a great question.
SIGGI CHEREM: So one thing
that we didn't talk much
today, but essentially, Web
Components have the notion of
a life cycle.
And currently, every component
has essentially four
methods that are--
or three--
three methods that
are being called.
There's a [? own ?]
created event.
There's a insert it
and remove event.
The idea is that any cleanup
that you need to do, basically
you should do it when you're
doing the remove method or
remove lifecycle method
of a component.
But yeah, I don't know
if you want to add
something about that.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
It's basically like--
if the component was created--
if you're writing the
component instantiation in HTML,
like if you're writing a
tag, especially if you put it
inside a template, then we
have the capability of doing
the cleanup completely
automatically.
And that's one of
the benefits.
There's nothing you can
get wrong there.
If you're creating in code,
as a limitation right now,
because we can't extend actual
DOM elements, you are going to
have to call removed and
tell us that you're
removing the things.
But that's a limitation
that we're going
to lift pretty soon.
It's just the state of things
as they are now.
It's basically like the state
of things right now is it's
going to be much more automatic
and managed for you
if you're able to use templates,
and if you're able
to keep your component
instantiations in the HTML.
JJ BEHRENS: So I have
one more question.
Let's look out into the distant
future, because I like
to try to pretend like
I'm able to do that.
One thing that's really good
about, let's say, the Gmail
client on Android, is that it
synchronizes your mail.
And then you could be on an
airplane with no internet
connection reading and
responding to email.
And then when you get
connection again,
it sends the email.
Do you think we'll get to a
point in our frameworks where
we have some framework concept
of dealing with local storage
and synchronizing
with the server?
And do you think that Web
Components and MDV are just
one step along that path?
SIGGI CHEREM: Yeah, I think--
there's an architectural
question there, and then
there's also the part of, OK,
there's a lot of pieces that
would need to be there in
order for it to work.
So handling synchronization in
the background and handling
offline is something that by
itself is already a challenge
of just, how do you manipulate
data from
one side to the other?
And then you have, how do you
present that data in your UI?
So this is where the triangle
that we talked about earlier
actually comes into play really
nicely, is that if you
make sure that most of your UI
reacts to changes in your
data, then planning a system
that is doing synchronization
in the background
is very easy.
All you're doing is pushing
those data changes as events.
And then those events are
watched by the UI.
And then you have that
UI reflecting all
those changes out.
But yeah, these are things
that are really
exciting to work on.
And I think that there's
a lot of--
we can even set this under this
big umbrella of how do we
solve all of these
UI problems.
I think that that would be one
task that definitely needs to
be tackled.
And it would be cool
to look into it.
JOHN MESSERLY: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
Guys, thank you so much
for taking the time.
I know that we have a few
questions left, but we're
running out of time and we'll
answer those offline.
Thanks again from sunny
Seattle from joining.
And thank you guys
all for watching.
And stay tuned for the next
episode of Dartisans.